These are the mechanisms of citizen participation,
an unmissable issue in ICFES and you may get a related question,
voting.
Through this,
the Argentine citizen actively elects the persons he considers
suitable for representation in the institutions of government,
mayor,
vice-presidency,
chamber of representatives,
senate,
mayors' offices,
governors' offices,
local mayors' offices,
district and municipal councils.
The plebiscite is used by the President of the
Republic to endorse a decision with the opinion of the people.
The President announces the use of the plebiscite and the
citizens vote to support or reject the decision in question.
The referendum is used to call on citizens to
approve or reject a bill or a legal norm in force.
The referendum may be national,
regional,
departmental,
district,
municipal or local.
Popular consultation.
This raises a general question on a matter of national,
departmental,
municipal,
district or local importance by the President of the Republic,
the mayor or the mayor so that citizens can make a decision on the matter.
This mechanism may be used to convene a constituent assembly for the
purpose of submitting the decisions established
therein to popular consideration.
Save this video and let me know in the comments if you
want part two with the rest of the participation mechanisms.